you guys trying to figure out what to
play on the switch there's a lot of
Indies on the switch and today you know
on the strain team of we're gonna be
presenting you a review but you know
Lord addicts gonna be presenting your
review for the Omega strike it's made by
a I'm gonna butcher this name really bad
I try to find a ways to pronounce it on
the internet but I'm gonna go ahead and
try my artists wobbly where I think it's
published and produced published and
produced it's developed and published by
uh Wally where wobbly where that's
that's the last time I'm trying but
anyway let's go to get on to the actual
review itself so you know it's kind of a
what's the one I'm looking for you know
those old vibe you get from playing
those Metroid games back in the day you
know Metroid where you have to get
certain abilities to go to certain areas
one of the things I really liked about
this game is it has a lot of that to it
another thing I really liked about this
game is you can actually switch between
three characters Oh someone with a
shotgun
someone will for grenade launcher it's
someone that just has a you know your
standard assault rifle they all have
their own unique abilities so you know
like the big dude with the grenade
launcher you use him to get into certain
parts of the mess because he can push
big objects the dude with the the
machine gun he can actually roll and go
under these little crevice parts of the
map where you can't normally get to
without him but the game starts where
you're trying to go after every search a
research scientist and he is doing some
weird stuff and what he does is you
finally catch on to where he is it's the
first five minutes of the game I'm not
gonna go I'm not could even show too
much of the gameplay in the background
this shows anything maybe two hours of
gameplay I'm not I don't want to really
ruin anything but you know you're trying
to go to this place where he is and the
scientist that's what that you know is
helping you with this he actually comes
up with this
this tech that lets you switch him back
and forth between these three
individuals pretty pretty seamlessly
what's really cool is at the beginning
of the game I try to put it on the
screen right when I'm talking it
actually shows what happens when you do
switch between these three two of them
are playing I think it's pong and ones
playing a guitar or something like that
so I thought that was really cool as
well when it comes to the switch I
honestly don't think there's a whole lot
to play on the switch regardless what
people seem to think but I do think this
is something that's really worth the
money
now obviously you know here are in Lords
podcast we did get the review code from
Wally where so we don't really have that
of you know that perspective of no I
don't really know what the price is I
would say it's $20 I can't quote
anything I haven't looked on the store
because once you redeem something you
can't see the price so I think that's
dumb that that's how my xbox in
PlayStation 2 I think they should let
you see it regardless if you own it or
not yeah I think it should show the
price when you click on it should say
that you already own it but this is a
really good game for anyone this has a
switch you know you get a lot of fun out
of it there are really unique bosses in
this game so definitely go check that
out there's a lot of good stuff in this
game you guys one of the things I really
enjoyed about it there's just the free
room you know that Castlevania Romania
way that people like same work you need
certain abilities to get some you know
I'll go ahead and say right now cuz it's
only in the first mission of the game
but you eventually get separated from
your other two so what happens is when
you're separated from the other two you
actually have to go and find them so you
don't have that big do to move those
logs you don't have you know they do
with the shotgun you don't have that dog
dogs role and you actually get double
jump which you lose that as well when
you get separated from your teammates so
what happens is you need to go
throughout the missions
and do stuff for you know the variety of
different NPCs to find these people
again to be able to get to these areas
that you used to be able to get to but
when he separated your people you had to
go back and you got to find those people
so a really good game the boss fights
are really unique for the switch is
definitely a good one kind I do feel
like certain games wouldn't get away
with stuff that other games do just
because they're all in the switch but
this is definitely a good game to be
playing on the switch I do believe it's
on Steam so you can always pick it up on
Steam if you want it's actually 65% off
on Steam right now so you can go pick
that up for looks like four dollars and
54 cents right now on December the 31st
I don't know when this Steam sale ends
so you have to you have to go do that
quick but anyway you know tell me what
you guys think I do think this is iron
Lords approved and I think you should go
out and pick it up especially if it's on
selling though on the switch - it might
be on sale there I think it is actually
put your call put your comments in the
section of it in the comment section
below if you think I don't know what I'm
talking about by noting the play on the
switch tell me what games down that you
like on this which you know will compare
see what you like on that and but then
anyway this is gaming addict I'm adding
a piece